bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver au sommaire de savourgarde ce
soir une ode à la parentalité bonsoir
jean-bne Baum merci d'être notre grand
témoin vous êtes journaliste essayis
seuls les enfants changent le monde
c'est votre dernier livre au seuil c'est
une réflexion à la fois intime
philosophique et politique hein sur la
question de l'enfant sur les enfants et
pas seulement sur la naissance même si
le monde est à l'agonie et bien le
discours du NO kids très peu pour vous
face à la puissance subversive du bébé
ça demande une explication on en parlera
tous les deux dans la deuxème partie
notre grand débat ce soir que peut faire
la communauté internationale dans la
guerre entre le ramas et Israël la
diplomatie semble totalement impuissance
après l'horreur absolue des massacre
dans l'État hébreu Israël s'apprête à
utiliser toute sa puissance pour
détruire le ramas le bain à Gaza est-il
le prix à payer nous en débatttrons
enfin ns affranchis ce soir il a elgos
pour son parti prix politique le regard
européen de Richard verli et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée signée Elsa Mondin Gava
voilà pour le menu on y va Jean bienbum
ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti 1200 mort côté israélien 1055 côté
palestinien bilan provisoire ce soir la
spirale de la violence est enclenchée on
croyait le ramas affaibli depuis la
contreoffensive le mouvement islamiste a
poursuivi ses tirs de roquettes dans le
sud d'Israël aujourd'hui une opération
terrestre à Gaza ne semble qu'une
question de jour maintenant et dans cet
affrontement qui s'installe dans la
durée la communauté internationale
a-t-elle encore son mot à dire c'est la
question qu'on va se poser ce soir
Nathalie Loiseau bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député européenne
renew c'est le groupe macroniste au
Parlement européen de Bruxelles et
ancienne ministre chargé des affaires
européenne bonsoir Simone rodan Benzaken
ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes la
directrice de l'American Jewish commitee
Europe bonsoir Marx so bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste au Monde et à challenge
euh vous êtes un ancien correspondant en
Turquie et vous connaissez bien le
Proche Orient et même le MoyenOrient
bonsoir David Rigolet rose bienvenue à
vous vous êtes chercheur aliris
spécialiste également du du Moyen-Orient
Jean Birnbaum voilà comme citoyen
n'hésitez pas à réagir à nous faire part
de votre émotion ou même voilà à
interroger nos nos invités on va
commencer avec la situation de ces
dernières 24 heures la riposte terrestre
israëienne à Gaza se prépare on voit
cela avec Stéphane dakovski dans son
chrono tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors on est 4
jours après après plus de 4 jours oui
après le début de l'attaque et pourtant
ce qui fait aujourd'hui la une de vos
quotidiens vous l'avez sans doute déjà
vu ou peut-être déjà vu ce sont de
nouveaux massacres découverts à la
frontière de Gaza ça fait la une du
monde aujourd'hui une édition spéciale
et vous voyez que des famill entière ont
été massacré assassiné sans pitié donc
face à ces atrocités joav Galand qui est
le ministre de la défense israélienne
s'est rendu sur place et il a répété ce
que disait déjà dimanche soir
netaniaahou Israël exercer une vengeance
implacable on
l'écoute vous avez vu ce que nous
combattons nous combattons contre les
animaux humain c'est le Daï de Gaza le
Hamas voulait changer la situation mais
ça va se retourner à 180°r ils
regretteront ce moment ils
regretteront alors de fait les
bombardements israéliens ont déjà fait
plus de 1000 morts à Gaza selon les
Palestiniens et l'objectif affiché par
Israël c'est d'éradiquer complètement le
Hamas qui suppose donc des une attaque à
priori de grande ampleur une attaque
terrestre du coup on peut malgré tout
s'interroger pourquoi le Hamas a-t-il
multiplier ces crimes atroces contre des
Israéliens qui plusait en diffusant des
vidéos de ces crimes atroces pour les
diffuser sur les réseaux sociaux sachant
que ça allait entraîner des réactions
d'autant plus violentes de la part
d'Israël donc on peut évidemment mettre
ça aussi un peu sur le compte du
fanatisme aveugle ça peut jouer mais
tout le monde a dit que cette attaque
était quand même savamment longuement
préparée donc forcément le Hamas a dû
réfléchir à l'avance à quelles seraient
les réactions d'Israël et donc si
eux-mêmes ont fait preuve d'énormément
de violence c'est ce-être pour entraîner
dans cette spirale de la violence Israël
et donc motiver des acteurs régionaux
d'entrer dans le conflit par exemple au
début du mois à la fin pardon du mois
d'août il y a un responsable du Hamas
qui avait menacé les Israéliens d'une
guerre régionale ça n'a peut-être pas
été pris très au sérieux pourtant il se
trouve que au début de l'année deux
milices islamistes rivales le Hezbollah
et le Hamas s'était rencontré hein VO
sous le parinage donc ça c'est le Hamas
ça c'est le hzbollah et sous le parinage
des Iraniens on voit ici un visage de
coméie donc la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que l'Iran le hzbolah pourrai
entrer en guerre contre Israël alors ça
c'est ce que veulent éviter à tout prix
les américains ils ont une priorité avec
la Chine ils sont engagés en Ukraine pas
question d'avoir une guerre en plus au
Moyen-Orient donc la manière forte bien
sûr comme toujours avec les Américains
ils ont déplacé un porte-avion ils ont
menacé de frapper tous ceux qui
voulaient profiter de la faiblesse
d'Israël mais en même temps pour éviter
cette guerre régionale on sent que les
Américains font aussi pression sur
Israël pour faire pr d'un peu de retenu
par exemple en ce moment les Américains
cherche à favoriser l'ouverture d'un
corridor humanitaire pour que les
population bombardé puissent être évacué
vers l'Égypte on écoute ce que Biden a
dit à netaniah lorsqu'ils sont parlé au
téléphone nous avons également discuté
du fait que des démocraties telles
qu'Israël et les États-Unis sont plus
fortes et plus en sécurité quand elles
agissent conformément au
droit terroristes cibleent délibérément
les
civils et les
tuent nous respectons les lois de la
guerre le droit de la guerre c'est
important il y a une différence alors
cet appel à la retenu sera peut-être
maintenant un peu plus facilement
entendu dès lors que israë a un
gouvernement d'union nationale depuis
cet après-midi nos experts nous
éclaireront à ce sujet du côté de la
France en tout cas on a pris position au
côté des Américains des Italiens des
Britanniques j'en oublié des Allemands
je pense pour assurer qu'il euh serait à
côté de Israël pour assurer sa défense
mais la question c'est savoir jusqu'où
israël peut-il aller pour assurer sa
défense côté français on n'aimerait pas
non plus que la viengence israélienne
provoque un conflit régional c'est pas
du tout l'objectif du gouvernement donc
gérrard Larcher qui était interrogé ce
matin qui est le président du Sénat lui
refusait de prendre parti pour une
incitation à la désescalade bien
pourtant c'est le le message qu'a fait
par passer pardon le gouvernement
français on écoute éivier Verron tout
doit être fait pour permettre d'éviter
la situation d'escalade au Moyen-Orient
protéger les civils éviter l'embrasement
du Moyen-Orient ces attaques
injustifiables terroristes du ramas ne
doivent pas nous détourner de la
recherche d'une paix durable et d'une
résolution politique des conflits alors
voilà je essayé de vous donner quelques
éléments pour suivre le débat qui va
s'entamer il y a-t-il un risque que ce
conflit débouche sur un conflit plus
vaste et ben place aux expert vous vous
le craignez vous l'embrasement de ce
conflit à ce stadel on est dans un dans
un face-
àface la la guerre au sol à gazas c'est
une question de jour et on entend
peut-être mise à part la voix de Jo
Biden très peu de poids diplomatique
dans le concert des nations ce soir très
peu personne ne pèse on a l'impression
que c'est vraiment un conflit à deux
d'abord il y a une guerre qui a été
déclenchée par le Hamas qui a attaqué
Israël c'est la première fois depuis la
création d'Israël
que le territoire israélien n'est plus
le refus
de ceux qui qui ont choisi d'y vivre
cette guerre existe et c'est un peu
irénique de parler processus de paix
négociation imaginez que on demande à la
France après le Bataclan de s'asseoir à
une table avec daesh c'est impossible
pour vous ramass c'est daesh c'est la
même chose il y a aucun doute làdessus
c'est ce qu'a dit benamin netaniaou on a
vu les horreurs qui ont été commises euh
moi ça me rappelle la dernière fois que
j'ai vu de mes yeux des horreurs de ce
type c'était à bcha c'est de ce
niveau-là donc commençons par ça et bien
sûr
qu'Israël va vouloir retrouver sa
sécurité bien sûr qu'Israël va vouloir
affaiblir le Hamas personne n' dire quoi
que ce soit contre ça personne n'a à
dire quoi que ce soit mais est-ce qu'il
faut appeler à la retenue à Gaza parce
qu'il va y avoir une guerria urbaine ou
est-ce qu'au contraire ça n'est pas
d'actualité face à ce queisraël a subi
après il y a deux choses est-ce que
toute la population palestinienne c'est
le Hamas bien sûr que non et le Hamas a
pris en otage les habitants de Gaza les
efforts pour essayer d'ouvrir un
corridor humanitaire pour par exemple
évacuer des femmes des enfants de Gaza
ça existe ça son des à soutenir c'est
compliqué via l'Égypte c'est compliqué
parce que l'Égypte a peur euh d'importer
du terrorisme et on la comprend aussi
mais évacuer des femmes et des enfants
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
évidemment soutenir c'est une des rares
choses qu'on puisse faire aujourd'hui et
empêcher dissuader d'autres pays de
laisser faire des attaques depuis leur
sol je pense évidemment au Liban Simon
rudan Benzaken euh vous vous avez
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs en Israël qui
évidemment
profondément bouleversé choqué par ce
qui leur arrive et en même temps en rage
on on a l'impression que c'est c'est le
mot que reprend beaucoup Frédéric Ansel
le géopolitologue ces derniers temps en
disant il faut éradiquer le ramasse et
c'est ça la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui pour l'ensemble du pays vous
le sentez comme ça oui on je je suis
entièrement d'accord avec Nathalie
Loiseau il faut il faut se rendre compte
ce qui a été vécu là par la population
israélienne
h la réalité c'est que je pense on a on
a sur l'échelle de l'histoire de
l'humanité jamais vécu ça c'està-dire
vous parliez de
bcha effectivement c'est c'est comme les
crimes
àoucha mais en plus de ça tout est
diffusé et expressément diffusé
c'est-à-dire on a tout sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui les terroristes
appellent les famille en voit ils
trouvent sur leur sur leur portable sur
le portable de leurs enfants le nom
maman et papa et ils envoient en direct
les meurtres des enfants donc il faut
comprendre le traumatisme que cela et
Catrine Colona d'ailleurs ce soir he la
ministre des Affaires étrangères dit que
ces attaques terroristes s'apparentent à
des crimes contre l'humanité sans aucun
doute sans aucun doute et donc donc
effectivement là aussi je suis d'accord
on peut pas demander on peut pas
demander la retenue bien évidemment je
le gouvernement israélien et encore plus
un gouvernement d' d'union nationale ne
souhaite pas la mort d'enfants et de
femmes palestiniennes c'est évident et
tout ce qui peut être fait pour sauver
la population palestinienne elle cela
doit être fait mais encore une fois la
question de de de de d'éradiquer cette
organisation terroriste elle est
absolument elle nécessaire Marc c'estot
éradiquer le ramasse c'est une idéologie
le ramasse ce sont des homes homme
aujourd'hui il y a même un chef ça veut
dire quoi très concrètement comment
comment vous imaginez cette opération
terrestre d'abord la hamass bon c'est un
mouvement politique mais c'est aussi une
organisation il a sa branche militaire
une organisation terroriste avec
quelques 40000 combattants maintenant un
peu moins 35000 donc voilà ils sont là
ensuite éradiqué c'est effectivement
compliqué vu la densité de la population
à Gaza vu le il y a des expériences
précédentes en 2014 en 2006 on a vu à
quel point c'est compliqué en plus le
Hamas
non seulement prend en bouclier humain
ses otages qu'il a enlevé mais y compris
la population de Gaza ses centres de
commandement sont installé sous les
hôpitaux donc évidemment il y aura une
pression rapidement de l'opinion
internationale pour le moment Israël
c'est la victime bah ça peut basculer
très vite ensuite pour expliquer
pourquoi actuellement aucune médiation
internationale n'est envisageable c'est
que non seulement il y a eu 1200 morts
qui ne s'était jamais vu dans l'histoire
d'Israël des civils mais ces 1200 morts
bébé compris ont été tués uniquement du
seul fait d'être juif c'est quelque
chose qui en
Israël ravive tout les cicatrices de la
choix sauvagerie jamais v C'est pas
seulement de la ch et de ce point de
vue- là c'est
pire c'est exactement l'imaginaire de
l'arrivée des nazis dans les villages
Ukrainiens Juifs où maison par maison on
descendaiit les gens et donc face à ça
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer une seconde
que la réponse d'Israël ne soit pas
terrible et à cet égard compréhensible
même si c'est évident et Joe Biden est
dans son rôle d'appeler Israël pas la
rtinue mais au respect du droit
international c'est vrai que
traiter gaz même si cel masse d'animaux
et dire qu'on va leur couper leire un
Absu c'est pas nécessairement très
habile politiquement mais cette réalité
est là et je ne vois pas pour le moment
qu'est-ce qui pourrait l'empêcher Israël
d'aller jusqu'au bout dans donc on est
là dans une guerre avec une souveraineté
d'un État qui a été plus qu'attaqué les
mots nous manquent euh et et et la
question de la diplomatie ou même de de
la
négociation on nous dit à lire certains
articles de la presse américaine que il
y a des il y a des contacts techniques
avec le ramas en ce moment euh c'est
possible oui alors si c'est des rumeurs
effectivement de de de négociation
notamment par le biais de du du Qatar
qui est d'ailleurs un des sponsor
financier hein du ramas historiquement
parlant voire de la Turquie mais là on
retrouve le le lien frériste puisque
frèr du Qatar enfin du ramas et et
d'obédience sunite he et pas chite
justement pour revenir et puis il y a la
question égyptienne les égyptiens sont
très très réticents parce que ils ont
pas envie de de recevoir un flux de
réfugiés qui passe par le par Rafa donc
en
réalité on n'est pas dans une logique on
va dire une dial lectique de négociation
de toute façon donc c'est c'est assez
illusoire de penser que ça va ça va
déboucher sur quelque chose et ce
gouvernement d'urgence d'union nationale
donc qui a été formé aujourd'hui avec
l'entrée de benigand qui est parti
d'opposition euh unité nationale ça veut
dire ça veut dire quoi que pendant toute
la durée de la guerre toutes les
décisions seront prises de façon plus
concerté ou ça veut dire
que le pays est derrière Israël de façon
totale ça c'était une nécessité
politique et même stratégique parce que
il y avait de toute façon une situation
pour qui était pas gérable pour Benjam
netanahou d'autant que la question des
responsabilités politiques c'est pas le
moment de les poser mais elle se POS ça
viendra
moment et donc il était nécessaire que
il y a une union sacrée qui qui
effectivement est faite et ça suppose
effectivement que ça s'exprime aussi au
nouveau gouvernemental pour qu'il y ait
un consensus sur les décisions très
difficiles qui vont être prises en plus
max c'est faire rentrer des experts
cabinet de guerre parce que jusqu'ici ce
gouvernement à part le ministre de la
défense c'est quand même illustré par sa
totale incompétence il y avait aucun
spécialiste des questions militaires et
ce qui est encore plus scandaleux pour
les Israéliens d' la rage de l'opinion
israélienne c'est qu'aucun de ces
ministres n'a été sur les lieux de la
tragédie ne serait-ce que pour on des 4
jours après ne serait-ce que pour dire
aux gens on est avec vous on vous
comprend on fera des choses le ministre
de la
défenseé on l' vu là aujourd'hui mais il
g mis le temps HM alors euh il y a cette
opération militaire qui se prépare c'est
quand même 300000 soldats réservices qui
sont à la frontière on a compris euh euh
les les enjeux il y a le risque d'un
double front il y a eu une fake news euh
aujourd'hui en tout cas une information
qui a été démentie ce soir une
infiltration aérienne n'a pas eu lieu
via le Liban euh au nord du pays il
n'empêche que il y a eu déjà des requêes
depuis le hzbollah Libanais est-ce que
ce ce double front est possible est-ce
que vous y croyez ou est-ce qu'au regard
des rapports de force et notamment
américains vis-à-vis du hbollah libanais
et et de l'Iran ça ne sera pas le cas
alors dire que ça ne sera pas le cas euh
ce serait être dans une rationalité
dangereuse il faut tout faire pour que
ça ne soit pas le cas il y a même le
risque d'un triple front en sixjordanie
donc les efforts diplomatiques qui sont
pas nécessairement publiques c'est quoi
c'est exactement ces efforts
diplomatiques
c'est dissuader le
hzbollah faire pression sur le Liban
faire pression sur les Parin du
hzbollah pour expliquer que rien de tel
que un 2è ou un 3è front ne pourrait
être toléré sans conséquence immédiat ça
veut dire une entrée en guerre des
Américains ça veut dire quoi ça peut
beaucoup de choses vous savez ça peut
dire de l'action des services de
renseignement ça ça ça peut dire
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et je suis
convaincu que un certain nombre de pays
occidentaux et peut-être de pays de la
région pèse dans cette direction parce
que ça c'est la première urgence
diplomatique je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'on ne me parle pas de désescalade
intern ou de dialogue avec les
Palestiniens aujourd'hui mais que on
évite que la région s'embrase ça c'est
absolument indispensable il y a des
camps de réfugiés palestiniens dans
toute la région il faut être très
vigilant sur ce qui s'y passe il faut
aussi être infiniment plus vigilant
qu'on ne l'a été et malheureusement
semble-t-il que les autorités
israéliennes ne l'ont été sur les
livraisons d'armes et sur les livraisons
de munitions comment se fait-il que le
Hamas ait pu avoir autant
d'armement il semble que l'Égypte aurait
prévenu à un certain niveau service de
renseignement israélien ça ça y est hein
c'est plus que des professionnels
arrivent comme disait Mar le
renseignement égyptien avait prévenu
pourquoi d'une opération d' pas dire
clairement désigné clairement parce que
si le hzbollah agit au nord exactement
c'est avec l'accord de Tran le pays qui
a planifié cette opération et maintenant
toutes les informations reviennent
remontent avec ça c'est l'Iran donc
celui qui a mis en garde Joe Biden en
disant de que tout pays qui profiterait
de de la situation a on subir les
conséquences c'est une espèce de phrase
dans ce genrel c'est l'Iran donc ayons
le courage de nommer l'Iran présent de
la République a dit un lien
vraisemblable oui voilà mais on reste qu
déjàqué par ailleurs qui é sor on reste
quand même extrêmement mou du j or la
menace clairement c'est l'Iran si le
hzbolla intervient si le front nord se
rallume c'est l'Iran donc ça ne sert à
rien de se cacher donc la question qui
se pose est-ce que nous sommes prêts
s'il le faut le Hamas a brûlé ses amars
a brûlé ses vaisseaux en lançant cette
offensive il sait qu'il n'y aura pas de
retour possible c'est la lutte à mort
avec Israël l'Iran qui désormais tient
totalement le Hamas ira-t-il jusqu'au
bout dans le soutien au Hamas c'est la
question que maintenant on peut se poser
et il faut explicitement là-dessus au
leeton vis-à-is de théran en désignant
clairement qui est l'agresseur
l'organisateur de cette tragédie si suis
absolument d'accord et je pense que par
ailleurs il faut se poser la question
pourquoi l'Iran à commandité entre
guillemets ce qui s'est passé là il y a
eu un développement dans la région c'est
que c'est que Israël s'est rapproché
d'un certain nombre de pays arabes on
appelle ça les accords d'Abraham et on
parlait de plus en plus deun potentielle
normalisation avec l'Arabie
Saoudite ça c'était un scénario
cauchemardesque pour l'Iran donc
clairement il y a un lien là-dessus le
la deuxième chose c'est que l'Iran dans
les différents messages qu'il a qu'ils
ont envoyé depuis des des mois c'est
qu'ils ont considérer que ce qu'il se
passait en Israël avec les
manifestations était un signe de
faiblesse et qu'il fallait exploiter ce
signe de faiblesse là et donc donc et
donc je pense effectivement la le TR la
troisième raison c'est que les
Iraniens ont je pense eu une lecture que
le monde occidental était premièrement
occupé avec autre chose vous avez parlé
effectivement de la priorité de
l'administration américaine avec la
Chine la question bien évidemment de
l'Ukraine et à a donc considéré que
c'était un bon moment effectivement pour
frapper et encore une fois je pense en
plus de ça que il y a eu une certaine
faiblesse ces derniers temps face à
l'Iran c'est-à-dire quand Joe Biden
l'administration américaine paye 6000
milliards de dollars pour libérer des
otages
américaines cela envoie un message
finalement aussi de faiblesse à à l'Iran
qu'est-ce qu'on sait des des moyens de
pression de discussion par des canaux
informels avec les Iraniens pour bien
comprendre il faut dire que l'arsenal du
hzbollah à la frontière libanaise c'est
quoi c'est 10 fois celui du ramas ça
rien à voir avec celui du Hamas hein
CELI de l'arsenal du Hamas il est
essentiellement endogène c'est qu' c'est
pas le résultat d'un flux que Perm un an
Contin continu de de livraison euh c'est
tout à fait différent avec le hbola qui
bénéficie justement de ce flux qui est
interrompu régulièrement d'ailleurs par
les frappes israéliennes sur la Syrie
puisque ça transite par la Syrie et
effectivement il dispose aujourd'hui
d'un arsenal d'un arcenal qui est estimé
selon les services de renseignement
israélien au au moins de 100000
roquettes et missiles ce qu' a 100000
oui ce qui est pas le cas de le de Hamas
qui avait pas de missile il a juste des
roquettes donc ça donne une idée de la
mesure d'un potentiel engagement du
ramas du du Hezbollah si quand on voit
ce que donne le résultat de 2000
seulement entre guillemets 2500 requêtes
par rapport au dô de fer qui qui n'est
qui de toute façon subit un effet de
saturation donc quand vous avez 10 fois
plus bah on a une idée de ce que ça peut
représenter en terme de menace dans
cette hypothèse que personne ne souhaite
bien évidemment là Israël ne peut plus
faire seul à double front il faudrait
l'intervention extérieure des Américains
qui qui annonce ce soir Washington
envoyer est prêt à envoyer un second
porteavion porteavion oui mais de toute
façon la la perspective c'est même pas
de double front quand vous disiez triple
front mais en réalité c'est multifront
c'est ce que disait également le
ministre de la Défense depuis un certain
temps c'est la la nouvelle situation
pour Israël c'est effectivement la
possibilité de se retrouver dans une
guerre multifront il y a Gaza
actuellement il y a le hzbola au Sud
Liban il y a les milices pro-iraniennes
en Syrie il y a les groupes armés de 6
Jordani qui se sont développés depuis 2
ans de manière spectaculaire de manière
inversement proportion d'ailleurs à la
disqualification de l'Autorité
palestinienne et puis et puis il y a le
tabou qui est aussi un tabou pour pour
la société israëlienne c'est les 20 %
d'Arab israélien parce que il y a eu un
message de Mohamed Daif qui est le le
chef de CELI qui a à la tête de cette
opération
desensiblement justement ostensiblement
les les Arabes israéliens à à participer
justement à la dynamique en courant donc
c'est vrai que c'est très préoccupant et
et évidemment le pire n'est jamais sûr
mais
c'est toujours préférable de l'anticiper
alors justement on sent que les voies
diplomatiques peineent à se faire
entendre Marc c'esto je voulais vous
passer un petit sujet vous voulaz
rajouter quelque chose oui a
diplomatique je suis sûr que la
rencontre à Bruxelles entre le ministre
des des Affaires étrangères israélien
qui a déjà dit qu'il n'irait pas le
ministre des Affaires
étrangères de l'autorité palestin de
sens c'est la député européenne qui le
dit va sûrement être un un point
intéressant pour essayer deés 20 absence
de de de diplomatie notamment européenne
dans la région que pourquoi c'est comme
ça qu'on reprend initiative vous pensez
pas du tout je dis ça n'a aucun sens je
dis ça n'a aucun sens et d'ailleurs pour
pourquoi l'UR c'est à ce point désengagé
diplomatiquement parce que l'Europe est
une rentière de la paix parce que elle a
cru avec une énorme naïveté et un énorme
égoïsme que ce qui lui arrivait à elle
se passait partout dans le monde que
c'était la fin de l'histoire que
l'écroulement de l'Union soviétique
voulait dire que on a les vivre
tranquille on a eu des des des des des
termes quand quand je pense par exemple
au Kabak qui vient de subir une
épuration ethnique on appelait ça
pudiquement un conflit gelé ça voulait
juste dire qu'on l'avait oublié h on ne
s'occupait plus de grand-chose à part de
nous-même et en fait quand on ne
s'occupe pas du reste du monde c'est le
reste du monde qui s'occupe de nous
ouais et voilà un frond c'est quand même
ouvert en plus au sein même de de
l'Europe avec l'Ukraine je voulais vous
montrer ce ce sujet qui oppose un
certain nombre de de politiques entre un
commissaire européen certains députés
français sur la question de la
suspension de l'aide humanitaire à Gaza
européenne française vous réagirez juste
après c'est signé Baptiste Garg
Chartier tout est parti de ce tweet qui
a provoqué un cafouillage au sommet de
l'Europe l'ampleur de la terreur et de
la brutalité contre Israël et son peuple
marque un tournant il n'est pas possible
de faire comme si de rien nétait ce
commissaire européen exige que tous les
paiements soient suspendus sauf que
cette annonce est faite à titre
individuel d'un proche du Premier
ministre hongrois face à ce quak la
Commission européenne rectifie le tir
pas question de suspension mais plutôt
une révision et bien sûr en concertation
avec tous les autres pays européens
alors la question qui divise et
fragilise l'unité des 27 la voici
l'Union européne
doit-elle encore accorder des aides
financières à la Palestine pour
l'Espagne l'Irlande le Portugal ou
encore la France il faut maintenir ses
aides cette aide est concentrée sur le
soutien aux populations palestiniennne
dans les domaines de l'eau de la santé
de la sécurité alimentaire et de
l'éducation versée notamment par le
biais des Nations Unies elle bénéficie
directement à la population
palestinienne à Jérusalem est en
Cisjordanie à Gaza et dans les camps
situés dans les pays voisins en revanche
l'URE est à la suspension de ces aides
pour l'Allemagne ou encore la Suède qui
emboîte le pas à d'autres pays européens
plusieurs autres pays de l'Union
européenne ont annoncé une révision et
une suspension de l'accord sur la
Palestine le derniè en date est le
Danemark qui arrête son aide mais aussi
l'Autriche la République
tchèque pour faire taire cette
cacophonie les 27 étatmembres se sont
réunis hier pour trouver une unité au
moins de façades en R appant
l'importance d'un soutien financier
durable au
Palestiniens voilà c'était un sujet de
de Maé Frémont bien sûr Nathalie
l'oiseau chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est
ça sur cette question là en Europe alors
chaque pays peut faire ce qu'il veut
heureusement mais en revanche en a un
qui a fait n'importe quoi c'est le
commissaire hongrois suspendre en un
tweet en plus la méthode est
hallucinante 600 millions d'euros pour
l'année prochaine pour la population
palestinienne il n'en avait pas le droit
il n'a consulté personne euh il fait
privé il est revenu hein
sur non non la Commission européenne l'a
forcé à à à à revenir mais moi je
voudrais surtout qu'il nous explique
c'est lui qui a la charge de cette aide
nous parlementaires européens tous les
ans quand nous examinons le budget avant
de donner notre autorisation nous
rappelons des règles extrêmement
strictes aucun financement ne doit aller
au Hamas vous pensez que c'est c'est
Orban qui lui a demandé à son
commissaire soit il ne sait pas ce qu'il
fait soit il ne sait pas gérer son aide
et à ce moment-là il faut qu'il
démissionne soit il sait que cette aide
ne va pas au Hamas et il sème le doute
et il sème le soupçon sur l'image de
l'Union européenne et là aussi il faut
qu'il démissionne moi j'appelle très
clairement à la démission du commissaire
varelli qui fait un agenda purement
hongrois sur ce sujet dramatique au
moment le plus grave mais qui va aussi
il est aujourd'hui en Serbie il a
soutenu les séparatistes de la
République serbe de de
Bosnie il va à peu près partout sur
l'Ukraine au lieu d'aider à préparer le
le démarrage des négociations d'adhésion
à chaque fois qu'il y va il parle du
sort des minorités hongroises il est
totalement en roue libre et j'aimerais
que Madame Van derl se rende compte de
la gravité de le message est passé on va
voir s'il est entendu il y a des
élections européennes bientôt donc pas
sûr qu' démission d'ici là Simon rod sur
la question de l'IDE moi je ne rentrerai
pas voyais lever le sourc sur le conflit
avec avec le commissaire varelli c'est
pas mon sujet par contre je pense que la
question qu'il a en tout cas soulevé est
importante il y a pas uniquement la
question du Hamas il y a la question
plus large de de la
Palestine je pense pas qu'il
faut suspendre toute aide aux
Palestiniens je pense que ça serait très
dangereux potentiellement pourrait
amener un effondrement de l'Autorité
palestinienne on en a aucun intérêt par
contre il faut aussi être très clair
aussi sur les jagissements pas
uniquement de du ramas mais aussi de
l'Autorité palestinienne l'Autorité
palestinienne selon les
estimations dépense 8 % de son budget
pour donner de l'argent au famille de ce
qu'ils appellent les
martyres les livres scolaires les manuel
scolaire continue à être un problème la
question de l'acheminement de l'aide où
va où va l'aide et qui qui la touche ça
fait des années ça faité en Europe il
faut faire le ménage sur les sur les
aides David rigagos c'est cette question
là il faut continuer l'aide mais est-ce
qu'on est sûr qu'elle va à au bonnes
personnes au bonne population c'est
c'est le le débat qui traverse
actuellement les les pays européens
effectivement et qui montre qu'il y a
pas consensus du tout là-dessus c'est un
sujet sensible parce qu'effectivement il
y a une dimension humanitaire euh qui
est qui est incontournable d'ailleurs
c'est la vocation de l'aide en question
donc et puis sinon il y a la question de
l'allocation précise euh la question de
la tutelle de de l'attribution et cetera
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il y a une
dimension là politique et plus seulement
humanitaire c'est trop opaque je vous
donnerai le mot de la fin sur ce sujetl
Marx oui et surtout c'est pas assez
conditionné notamment justement sur
cette question desemmanuel scolaires
surt beaucoup d'autres question
conditionné depuis plusieurs années moi
tous les ans je rajoute un amendement au
budget pour nous assurer que pas un € ne
va à desem manuels scolaires qui
contreviendrai nos nos valeurs notamment
sur l'antisémitisme sur l'antisionisme
et on a vu d'énormes progrès sur la
question ce que je veux dire c'est que
cette aide elle est versée avec l'accord
du gouvernement israélien elle rend
service à Israël et suspendre cette aide
c'est faire le jeu du Hamas c'est avoir
l'air de confondre la population
palestinienne avec un groupe terroriste
sanguinaire et c'est poussé une jeunesse
dans les bras des plus radicaux qui
viendra en aide à ce moment-là euh à à
ces populations certainement pas euh
comme l'Union européenne des gens qui
demandent des progrès dans l'État de
droit des progrès dans la lutte contre
la corruption ce sera les pires des fin
de ce débat les pires des sponsors dur
je veux juste me permettre une chose euh
oui pas la suspension mais au moins
comme dit Marc c'est mot la le
conditionnement sur un certain nombre
critè plus rigourux ce débat de toute
façon il est il est ouvert l'heure est
malheureusement à à la guerre merci
beaucoup on a appris des choses merci
pour vos expertises vous avez écouté ça
attentivement Jean birnebaum j'ai eu
l'impression voilà vous n'aviez pas
forcément envie de rentrer dans dans ces
débats difficile et complexégitime mais
c'était passionnant alors vous restez
avec moi dans une dizaine de minutes
merci à vous on va accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti prix ce soir
c'est Yael gouse qui va revenir sur les
effets de l'attaque du ramas sur les
chiquier politique français Richard ver
va nous éclairer sur les élections de
dimanche en Pologne et puis Elsa
mondinavan de quoi nous parlez-vous dans
Bourbon Express ce soir bien
transpartisan ça veut dire qui dépasse
l'éclivage des partis et vous allez le
voir ça existe un peu à l'Assemblée mais
d'abord on va se plonger dans votre
livre jean-bne Baum seuls les enfants
changent le monde quel titre aux
éditions du Seuil c'est un témoignage je
le disais personnel assez intime
politique une réflexion philosophique
aussi sur l'aventure aussi décisive que
boulever versante que l'enfance en C
temps d'écho anxiété regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier et on en
parle tous les deux juste
après si on vous invite jeanbirnbaum
c'est parce que vous lancez un SOS
faites des enfants des bambins boutchou
chérubin et autres pitchun ces petits
êtres énigmatiques qui chamboulent nos
vies à commencé par la vôtre moi en ce
moment mais je vois j'assiste à cet
incroyable miracle qui sauve le monde et
qui est un miracle toujours renouvelé
des premières fois la première fois que
la main se se ferme sur un objet la
première fois que un mot est proncé la
première fois qu'il y a un rire qu'il y
a de l'ironie père de trois rechetons
mais aussi journaliste à la tête du
monde des livres depuis 12 ans essayiste
à la plume remarquée on retiendra votre
éloge de la nuance en 2021 aujourd'hui
place à l'éloge de l'enfance l'enfance
une obsession chez vous qui raisonne
avec votre histoire familiale avec celle
de votre grand-mère contrainte pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale de cacher son
fils votre père parce qu'il était juif
sauver ses enfants ce n'est pas
seulement protéger la chair de sa chair
c'est aussi résister au nazis entraver
leur projet d'annihilation procréé pour
survivre mais l'époque a bien changé
jeanbnbaum plus de 8 milliards d'humains
sur terre et une natalité qui dégringole
dans les pays développés notamment en
France 700000 bébés l'année dernière
contre 800000 en 2014 une tendance qui
inquiète à l'heure du mouvement nos kids
ces jeunes qui ne veulent pas d'enfants
dans un monde en plein bouleversement et
qui ne cessent de se réchauffer moi
j'appelle juste à essayer de comprendre
ces jeunes qui ne se sentent pas assez
en sécurité pour pouvoir procréer faire
moins d'enfants pour sauver la planète
une revendication un idéal politique que
vous interrogez jeanbnbaum à quoi bon
sauver un monde sans enfants alors on a
une question pour vous ce soir comment
redonner à la jeunesse l'envie d'être
parent réponse bah je sais pas bien
parce que Mo en plus je me considère pas
du tout comme une sorte de prédicateur
de maternité ou de prêcheur de de bébé
mais euh comment donner envie bah je
pense tout simplement pas tellement par
des grands discours ou des théories moi
je passe par un livre mais parce que je
suis bien obligé mais parce que mais
mais j j'ail en permanence les
réflexions et l'émotion et je pense que
convaincre la jeunesse ou lui redonner
l'envie d'être parent c'est d'abord lui
redonner l'espérance pour moi c'est
évident que la crise de des naissances
c'est d'abord une crise de l'espérance
c'est que si tant de jeunes aujourd'hui
se posent des questions voir renonc à ce
désir d'enfant bah c'est parce que
l'avenir semble boucher l'avenir
politique l'avenir humain mais vous les
comprenez vous les comprenez c'est pas
ce ce discours du NO Kid c'est pas
quelque chose que vous condamnez pas du
tout pas du tout mais moi-même je l'ai
longtemps porté en fait j'ai grandi dans
une famille très à gauche on considérait
que le monde était très lait que
l'histoire était épouvantable qu'il y
avait des guerres partout qu'il y avait
eu la torture en Algérie au Chili
partout enfin j'ai grandi dans cette
ambiance là et l'idée de mettre un
enfant au monde dans dans dans cette
atmosphère de de violence d'inégalité
d'injustice et cetera c'était évidemment
quelque chose dont on se disait en fait
il faut être un peu taré pour ça alors
c'est quoi le déclic de ce livre
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à essayer de
comprendre votre obsession de l'enfant
puisque c'est ce que vous racontez vous
avez découvert que vous aviez ça est-ce
que c'est la naissance de votre dernière
fille vous avez trois enfants qui est
petite aujourd'hui est-ce qu'au
contraire c'est c'est les débats d'
actualité en fait a déclenché ce livre
c'est c'était super que le livre soit
cité avant enfin le précédent c'est que
en j'ai écrit c'est c'est tout simple
j'ai écrit le courage de la nuance parce
qu'il y avait une ambiance que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi ou mieux
que moi une ambiance de brutalisation du
débat public et j'avais envie de faire
une espèce de câlin mélancolique à
toutes les femmes tous les hommes qui
étouffent dans les dans dans le moment
actuel de de de brutalité de mauvaise
foi de haine et cetera et puis ce livre-
là le courage de la nuance essayie
d'expliquer que un tel courage n'est pas
théorique n'est pas conceptuel qu'il est
ancré dans des choses très concrètes
très ordinaires l'amitié la maladie des
choses qui vous font découvrir votre
finitude qui vous font un peu renoncer à
votre arrogance à votre mauvaise foi et
cetera et quand j'ai eu fini ce livre je
me suis dit mais c'est quand même dingue
tu as parlé tout toutes ces expériences
l'humour l'amitié la franchise la
maladie et cetera et il y a et tu n'as
pas dit un mot dans ce livre-là le
courage de la nuance sur l'expérience
quotidienne ordinaire sensible émue qui
pour toi donne le plus ce courage qui
est l'expérience de la rencontre avec un
un nourrisson la rencontre a le vôtre
c'est-à-dire que pas forcément dans la
la rencontre et cette expérience un lien
familial un lien parental non mais je je
montre effectivement je je le dis à
plusieurs reprises que ça peut être son
bébé le bébé de quelqu'un d'autre ça
peut même être un horizon de bébé je
cite plusieurs personnes qui ont écrit
des livres à des enfants qui dédiés à
des enfants qui ne sont pas nés ou qui
ne naîtront jamais je cite beaucoup Anna
arent la philosophe qui n'a pas eu
d'enfants alors justement on va prendre
trois philosophes à quoi bon sauver un
monde sans enfants vous convoquez les
philosophes qui sont chers votre cœur ce
que vous lisez que vous relisez sans
cesse et notamment Anna rent pour nous
dire à quel point l'expérience de
l'enfance est à la fois bouleversante
mais aussi politique et et même
subversive comment vous comprenez ce
paradoxe d'Ana Aren qui dit que la
natalité est au centre de la condition
humaine et qui elle-même n'a pas
souhaité faire d'enfants alors c'est
pasant qu'elle a pas souhaité elle
explique à un moment donné que c'est
très compliqué vous savez qu'elle a fu
l'Allemagne elle a fu les nazis elle
s'est retouve dans des conditions très
elle a failli connaître vraiment le pire
elle ensite réussi à s'exiler via la
France aux États-Unis donc à un moment
donné il y a pas beaucoup de traces
là-dessus mais il y a quelques traces
dire c'était trop préca vraiment une
question de de précarité mais il
n'empêche que elle fait partie des rares
philosophes occidentaux qui ont pris au
sérieux la question de la naissance et
de l'enfant du du nouveauné et qui ont
et qui a montré et elle a montré que
finalement on pouvait pas penser à un
nouveau monde sans au moins affronter
euh le problème ou la la perspective de
du nouveau- né ce qu'on appelle serit
simplement le nouveauné et les passages
qu'elle a sont hyper beaux c'estàd
qu'elle montre non seulement que les
enfants chaque naissance est comme un
miracle qui sauve le monde dit-elle et
ça justement on pourrait le dire à toute
cette jeunesse qui veut sauver le monde
que chaque naissance est un miracle qui
sauve le monde parce que chaque
naissance dit-elle c'est totalement
unique hein je résume ça en disant
chaque fois unique le début du monde ne
pas le début d'un monde chaque enfant
qui serait un monde non c'est comme si
il y avait personne avant et comme si
chaque enfant venait refonder le monde
avait une espèce de puissance inaugurale
incroyable qui faisait que il va nous
projeter dans un dans un espace où
toutes les certitudes Vass et où aussi
c'est pour ça que c'est le courage de la
nuance et aussi où tout tous les espoirs
sont permis donc pour elle effectivement
il y a il y a une évidence que non
seulement les enfants assurent la
continé la continuité du monde mais que
les enfants surtout sont garants de la
du pluralisme et de la démocratie en
réalité parce que elle a cette formule
elle dit chaque enfant est absolument
unique et euh les naissances à la fin ça
fait la paradoxale elle appelle ça la
paradoxale plural d'être unique voilà
chaque enfant est unique à la fin ça
fait cette pluralité et le pluralisme
c'est la définition de la démocratie et
on voit bien que encore là dans
l'actualité que vous avez évoqué juste
avant l'acharnement sur les bébés comme
comme en Ukraine et cetera la
déportation des enfants qui sont
russifiés et cetera en fait elle montre
bien comment le totalitarisme ne peut
pas supporter cette dissidence qui est
l'enfance et doit forcément aussi
toujours à un moment donné mettre la
main sur les enfants la disciidence de
l'enfance très très belle expression
George Bernanos end c'est philosophe
chrétien il excelle dans la description
de l'enfance vous racontez il a eu trois
filles trois garçons et il parle du
désastre métaphysique lorsque ses
enfants sont partis en pension
expliquez-nous ça bah oui parce que je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui qui qui
n'a pas cessé de considérer alors dans
une perspective très chrétienne que tout
élan de dissidence justement comme vous
disiez é un retour à l'enfance et
d'ailleurs donc pour lui être privé de
ses enfants c'étaitêtre privé de ce bain
rebelle de ce bain déstabilisant de ce
bain qui vous révèle à vous-même et
cetera et c'est très beau parce que vous
savez que berdanos est connu notamment
comme un grand écrivain mais aussi comme
quelqu'un qui a fait un geste
hallucinant de courage au moment de la
guerre d'Espagne il sait alors qu'il
était quelqu'un classé tout à fait à
l'extrême droite royaliste monarchiste
et cetera et bien il il a pas supporté
que le coup d'État du général Franco se
réclame de du Christ et du christianisme
pour commettre les crimes abominables
qui qu'il a commis et donc bernano s'est
retourné contre son propre camp et a
écrit ce livre magnifique s'appelle les
grands cimetières sous la lune or
qu'est-ce qu'il dit dans ce livre il dit
que finalement tout le livre consiste à
retrouver les accents de l'enfance à
retrouver sa voix d'enfant comme si
d'évidence prendre de la hauteur pour
lui c'était retomber en enfance alors la
dimension politique c'est intéressant
c'est drôle vous raconter la question de
l'enfant celle qui fragilise celle qui
déstabilise vous l'avez posé à à plein
de de personnalités que vous avez
interviewé de de Booba à l'historien
Pierre Nora Édouard ou Douard Louis
c'est intéressant parce que lui dit que
tout est politique y compris la vie
familiale la vie privée lui aussi parle
de la dissidence par d'une certaine
forme de militantisme pour un monde
meilleur et là la question le désarçonne
un peu racontez-nous oui B c'est très
curieux c'était un moment de débat
public comme ça où je l'interrogais je
lui demandais si des questions faciles
je lui demandais sil avait déjà fait une
psychanalyse des choses comme ça et un
moment donné je lui dit mais puisque
votre livre est sur la c'est son dernier
livre c'était sur sa mère qui est un
très beau livre moi j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'il fait je mais est-ce que vous
verriez un jour devenir père et il a été
totalement déstabilisé gêné presque à
faune comme ça il s'est mis à dire des
choses assez désevante finalement en
mode mais moi je comprends pas ces gens
qui sont esclaves derrière leur
poussettes ils pourraent être en train
de lire un livre de Marguerite Duras au
café ils sont là dans une il dit pour
moi c'est une violence inouie et cetera
et et un ami à lui don ils sont très
proches le sociologue jeoffroid de la
ganerie a fait un livre entier où il
explique un éloge de la musé beau où il
explique pour lui
vraimentir
c'est une vie de tristesse c'est une vie
d'esclave c'est une vie tout ça et moi
je trouve ça marrant quelque part enfin
touchant et et en même temps contestable
c'estd que finalement je trouve ça fou
que ce discours là qui décrit la vie de
parents comme quelque chose de de de de
triste de conformiste et cetera soit se
fasse passer pour subversif parce que
pour moi ce discours pardon c'est au
contraire une manière de se protéger de
ce qui a plus subversif dans la vie de
ce qui peut vous arriver c'estàd un
enfant qui vient et qui vous remet à
votre place qui vous ridiculise et qui
vous fait douter et qui devant lequel
vous pvez pas prendre la pause et sur
lequel vous pouvez pas non plus prendre
la main alors la question politique
c'est passionnant ce sera ma dernière
question euh ça fait très longtemps que
toutes les formes de radicalité
politique notamment à l'extrême gauche
les révolutionnaires abjurent leur désir
d'enfant c'est pas uniquement lié à
quelques radicalités écolo face au
réchauffement climatique aujourd'hui
vous-même vous avez été vous le racontez
dans le livre trotkiste dur vous étiez à
Lutte ouvrière et ce c'est une
organisation politique où on fait pas
d'enfant alors c'est pas a écrit hein
noir sur blanc dans des dans des lois
mais c'est une tradition d'ailleurs les
grands responsables femmes n'ont pas
fait d'enfants euh comment vous avez été
à l'aise dans dans dans ça vous avez
compris que comment vous vous preneiez
une distance avec ça ou pas justement ce
que j'explique c'est que j'ai jamais
vraiment été à l'aise en même temps j'ai
adoré bon je peux pas moi jouer à
l'ancien combattant c'est quelques
années très fugac dans les années 90
quand j'avais 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que euh
oui j'ai j'ai j'ai re ce groupe qui
était un groupe de de lecteurs un groupe
avait beaucoup d'ouvriers des gens très
cultivés des gens fascinants très
charismatiques qui avaient vécu plein de
choses lu beaucoup de choses aussi et
j'ai j'ai vu beau exu l'enfant du
domaine de la lutte mais qui avait
effectivement fixé comme règle pour
plein de raisons compliqué en partie
pertinente et cetera le fait que il
prévenaent tout le monde à l'entrée hein
quand les gens arrivaient disent mais
chez nous on ne fait pas d'fant et en
fait d'emblé et c'est un peu le livre un
peu d'enquête sur ce sentiment de
malaise d'emblé pour moi je me suis dit
mais comment c'est possible en fait que
on prétende comment on peut prétendre
vouloir changer le monde si on renonce à
donner la vie Rosa Luxembourg elle que
je cite beaucoup elle c'était évident
pour elle fa que on pouvait pas au moins
poser cette question du don de la vie si
on voulait changer le monde et en fait
moi je je je j'ai fini par me j'ai fini
par quitter ce groupe aussi là-dessus
c'est que pour moi il y a une sorte de
malaise je vois pas comment on peut
vouloir changer le monde si on pose pas
la question de la génération la question
de l'émancipation elle est forcément à
l'horizon des êtres qui viennent des
gens qui vont nous succéder et donc des
de ce qu'on appelle au sens le plus
charnel la génération merci Jean bon
voilà donc pourquoi seuls les enfants
changent le monde c'est à lire au seuil
vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti-prix ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite yel Goose de
franceinterre chef du service politique
éditorialiste bienvenue Richard verli et
son regard sur l'Europe du quotidien
suisse blique installez-vous on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
c'est l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
elle est signée ce soir Elsa mondinava
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais vous
raconter ce soir l'histoire de trois
députés qui nous ont invité à une
conférence de presse avec Marion de
Vauchel onci est rendu il lance un
groupe de travail je vous le donne en
1000 sur le travail rémunération temps
partiel subi semaine de 4 jours rapport
déjeunes avec le travail vaste débat
mais ce qui nous a intéressé c'était
moins le thème que le profil de ces
députés regardez il y a Astrid panogian
Bouvet Renaissance Stéphane viri les
républicains et Dominique potier
socialiste c'est donc ce qu'on appelle
un groupe
transpartisan gauche droite et majorité
vous pensez que vous allez tous vous
entendre ah c'est pas n'importe quelle
gauche c'est pas n'importe quelle droite
et c'est pas n'importe quelle majorité
c'est des personnes de bonne volonté qui
ont commun je crois une certaine
ouverture d'esprit des passions communes
et puis une certaine idée de la
démocratie la démocratie comme un lieu à
creuser on cherche la vérité ensemble on
l' pas tout seul je pense que des
moments comme la conférence de presse
que nous avons donné font du bien où on
voit d'abord des discussions de fond une
discussion apaisée et respectueuse les
un des des autres donc c'est important
aussi de montrer à nos concitoyens
d'abord qu'on regarde des sujets du
quotidien qui sont extrêmement
importants pour eux mais c'est aussi
important de montrer qu'on peut le faire
de manière apaisée et respectueuse ce
que vous voulez montrer c'est que
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas que des
invectives c'est pas que des insultes
c'est ça mais vous savez à notre notre
quotidien chaque semaine on travaille
beaucoup on se parle on échange on
avance le prisme médiatique ou l'image
que qui peut en résulter c'est et là
trop souvent frustrant pour pour un
député comme moi donc effectivement on a
l'idée effectivement de démontrer qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale il se passe des
choses très saines très utiles pour les
Françaises et les Français alors pour
l'instant dans ce groupe il y a 29
députés ils vont faire toute une série
d'auditions tous les députés étaient
bienvenus sauf le rassemblement national
qui est personnal non grata c'est vrai
que on s'attache souvent au aux
polémiques et au et aux tensions dans
l'hémicycle il y a des échanges en fait
réguliers entre groupes différents ou
oui c'est pas la seule initiative on
peut penser au groupe transpartisan sur
les déserts médicaux il y avait des
députés qui avaient fait des
déplacements ensemble ils avaient même
fini par faire des meetings communs
proposer des amendements en commun ce
matin encore des députés de différents
groupes politiques avaient donné
rendez-vous pour faire des propositions
alors sur un thème assez consensuel he
c'était les enfants et les écrans là
encore ils étaient présents sauf le
rassemblement national la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a même créé des
semaines transpartisanes avec l'examen
de proposition de loi majorité
opposition alors il s'agit pas de
minimiser les tensions en ce moment il y
en a beaucoup ça va même plutôt dégrader
l'ambiance que faire que ça aille mieux
mais il est important aussi de montrer
que ces initiatives elles existent il y
a des choses qui se passent bien à
l'Assemblée ex et ben vous l'avez fait
parfaitement merci beaucoup els a parti
prix de yel Goz on est 4 jours on le
disait après l'attaque terroriste du
ramas en Israël déjà les les effets les
effets sur les chiquers politiques
français et des effets Myriam qui seront
durables car on assiste à des scènes qui
auraient été inimaginables il y a 5 ou
10 ans c'est simple en 4 jours la France
insoumise 22 % la présidentielle à a
pris le risque fou de se marginaliser et
de se mettre au banc de la République on
est à front renversé à certains égards
elle et fille occupe la place de paria
qui fut longtemps celle du FN avant le
RN je m'explique ce qui s'est passé en
Israël c'est une démocratie attaqué un
massacre d'innocent un nouveau 11
septembre un Bataclan du néf appelez-le
comme vous voulez mais jamais en 4 jours
la direction de LFI n'ura lâché le mot
terroriste pour qualifier le Hamas
entêtement absurde chez LFI même quand
on est assiégé même quand on est à cours
d'arguments rationnel on ne se dédie pas
on ne s'excuse pas on fonce droit dans
le mur à quoi vous faites allusion avec
cette position intenable
elle fi prêtent le le flan aux
accusations d'antisionisme funé de
l'antisémitisme pourquoi faire du et en
même temps sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien dans quel but pour
flatter quel électorat quel March
électorale en en banlieu pourquoi se
couper à ce point des organisations
juives de France on va remonter le film
si vous voulez bien lundi soir pour la
première fois h députés RN sont dans le
cortège du criff en soutien à Israël et
c'est un socialiste Olivier fort seul
chef de parti de gauche présent ce
soir-là qui passe un mauvais quart
d'heure c'est lui c'est pas le RN qui
passe un mauvais quart d'heure hier à
l'Assemblée après la minute de silence
Marine Le Pen prend la parole pour dire
son soutien inconditionnel à Israël et
elle est applaudie par la droite LR les
républicains on les voir mais aussi dans
la majorité par une dizaine de députés
horizon et modem et ça c'est nouveau à
contrario quand l'insoumise Mathilde
Panau parle c'est une partie de
l'hémicycle qui se vide et enfin dernier
dernier image ce matin de ministres
Gérald haranin et Gabriel Atal sont à
Sarcel à l'école juive Osar à Tor bon
accueil sauf pour qui pour le député du
coin Carlos Martins bilongo député LFI
obligé de faire demi-tour Carlos Martins
bilongo rappelez-vous c'est le député à
qui le Ren avait crié il y a un an dans
l'hémicycle qu'il retourne en Afrique
donc trois images qui pour vous il a
elle sont le signe d'un renversement
complet d'un d'une inversion même ouais
plus LFI se radicalise et plus le RN
s'institutionnalise c'est spectaculaire
et ça se mesure dans la dernière enquête
hipsos fracture française LFI est
désormais perçu comme le parti le plus
dangereux pour notre démocratie
française c'est plus le RN qui était la
première place c'est LFI à contrario la
respectabilité du parti Jordane Bardella
monte en flèche 44 % des Français juge
le RN apte à gouverner et tout ça a été
mesuré avant l'attaque du Hamas avant
les polémiques sur LFI en politique il y
a des moments qu'on dit qui sont cliqués
c'est là que nous c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre le cliquet la
gauche se recomposera sans doute mais à
court terme ce sont ces malheurs qui
font le bonheur de Marine Le Pen la
diabolisation a changé de camp merci
beaucoup il a elgo ça va vous faire
réagir vous aviez écrit je me rappelle
le silence religieux la gauche face au
djihadisme aujourd'hui elle ne peut pas
cette extrême gauche là elle est fit
prononcer le mot de terrorisme elle ne
peut pas qualifier les faits on en est
là oui c'est vrai que il y a une
difficulté à prendre au sérieux ce qui
est en train de se passer mais
finalement il y a y a des a des
résonnances entre ce que vous avez dit
parce
que bah dans le courage de la nuance j'
essayé de montrer que quand dans dans
tout ce bordel toute cette violence il y
a rien de plus radical que que la nuance
et finalement on voit bien que dans la
scène politique il y a des gens qui
essayent qui voient très bien que les
clivages politiques tels qu'ils sont
figés ou et cetera ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut que tout le monde s'embrasse
et que tout le monde dise la même chose
mais en tout cas que sur les sur plein
de grands sujets des gens qui
n'appartiennent pas au même parti en
fait sont d'accord ils peuvent se parler
et peuvent faire droit à la parole de
l'autre et Albert Camu disait beaucoup
ça que en fait il faut savoir surtout
même même à son ennemi en fait accorder
que son ennemi peut avoir raison sur tel
ou tel point il disait que c'était le le
principe de base de quiconque a ce
rapport à la nuance à la mesure et
cetera et là c'est un peu la même chose
parce que finalement ce que vous disiez
sur ce ce parti qui est incapable de se
dédire dans c'était très beau ce que
vous avez dit là-dessus et c'est
incroyable parce que moi on connaît tous
des gens proches de Mélenchon enfin on
connait moi j'ai croisé des gens des
députés et cetera qui sont tous atterrés
et il y a cette espèce de discipline de
faire complètement et de et de non dit
avec des éléments de langage où tout
suinte la mauvaise foi et la peur et une
espèce de de gâchie incroyable où on
sent que effectivement on est dans tous
dans le courage de de la franchise de la
nuance alors qu'on sait très bien enfin
toute l'histoire du 20e siècle est là
pour nous montrer sans vous vouloir dire
les grands mots que il y a pas
d'espérance radicale qui va très loin
quand elle est quand elle est basée ou
armée par la mauvaise foi et une espèce
de de panique et de peur et de
discipline collective apeuré il est
inarrêtable vous avez ça l'a inspiré ou
prend des notes vous allez voir ça Mo je
voulais faire entre
vous ça va continuer peut-être à à nous
voilà nous terrifier cette Europe qui
pourrait basculer aux mains des enfin un
pays de plus non il y est déjà
d'ailleurs national populiste c'est la
Pologne vous nous parlez d'une élection
importante dont on parle peu évidemment
en ce moment c'est c'est l'élection
législative de dimanche prochain alors
Varsovie nouveau centre de gravité de
l'Union européenne c'est ce qu'on entend
depuis des mois sur fond de guerre en
Ukraine compte tenu du rôle décisif joué
par la Pologne sur le plan du soutien
militaire à Kiev première chose et aussi
pour l'accueil de millions de réfugiés
forte de 38 millions d'habitants et la
Pologne en plus a une insolente
croissance économique 5 % elle est un
nouveau géant européen alors j'emploie
le mot géant à dessin car nous parlons
sans doute du pays le plus proaméricain
de l'Union américaine et aussi le plus
antirusse donc tout ce qui s'y passe a
une importance absolument décisive pour
l'Union y compris sur le proche orient
alors là pour d' autre raison le passé
de la Pologne les camps de concentration
naz qui étaient sur son sol durant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale pè évidemment
toujours lourd alors au niveau européen
on peut marginaliser la Hongrie de
Victor Orban même si c'est pas facile on
l'a vu tout à l'heure à propos du
commissaire hongrois on peut ignorer la
Slovaquie de Robert fitzo ce nouveau
chef du gouvernement puisqu'il va
réussir à mettre en place une coalition
maisire de côté la Pologne parce qu'elle
pèse trop lourd c'est donc le sort de
l'Union qui se joue dimanche dans les
isoloirs polonais alors pour pour rappel
une victoire de l'actuel parti au
pouvoir le pis le parti droit et justice
qui est national populiste ça
signifierait que ce courant ultra
conservateur catholique eurosceptique
autoritaire anti-immigration prendra
encore plus racine les attaques contre
l'indépendance de la justice qui ont
conduit Bruxelles à geler des fonds
européens deviendrait presque impossible
à empêcher la Résistance polonaise à
toute autonomie stratégique européenne à
la mode Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire
distante des États-Unis serait encore
plus renforcé car polonais n'en veulent
absolument pas c'est le pis qui est
favoris des sondages alors ça devient un
peu compliqué donc avec beaucoup de
suspense en ce moment la coalition
civique de Donald Tusk l'ancien
président du Conseil européen est en
train de remonter pourquoi
essentiellement à cause de scandale
scandale de corruption scandale sur
l'attribution de visa aussi beaucoup de
Polonais ne comprennent pas pourquoi
d'un seul coup le gouvernement est fâché
avec l'Ukraine à cause des céréales
parce qu'on veut ménager les paysans
bref il y a un suspense électoral mais
attention même si l'actuel gouvernement
devait va être battu la Pologne elle ne
redeviendra pas un pays docile qui se
contente d'accepter les fonds européens
Varsovie veut compter et vaapuser et
Emmanuel Macron l'a bien compris parce
qu'il a toujours soigné ce qu'on appelle
le triangle de vaimmar c'est-à-dire
l'amitié la relation entre la France
l'Allemagne et la Pologne donc
rendez-vous dimanche ben oui et
rendez-vous en début de semaine pour
venir un peu décrypter ses résultats
merci beaucoup Richard merci y merci
Elsa Jean Baum merci à vous d'avoir
passé l'heure en direct seul les enfants
changent le
c'est votre dernier essai essai voilà un
peu psychanalytique et personnel très
intime et philosophique paru au Seuil
très belle soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain